so apparently this is worth discussing
oh great
because according to twitter it's the
number one thing on twitter right now so
i said on fox news this morning
uh that i don't believe in a stimulus
check because if you get 600
or 1400 and it changes your life you
didn't have a life you're already
screwed yeah
and apparently that's news to people
it's it's like apparently i've i have
upset and melted many snowflakes
so the concern is is what that
that 600 changes people's lives i mean
honestly
i thought it was a fairly obvious thing
if 600
changes your life your life really sucks
but i thought you don't have a life
you're screwed i thought both sides have
been upset about that
that that amount well it's not enough
right it's either not enough or why are
we sending it right
yeah it's well it's not enough or you're
not allowed to talk about not getting it
because apparently
it is freaking life-changing and i just
didn't know because i'm an elite boomer
huh i mean it's
what what asinine people are i mean some
of you people have lost your
dad blame minds out there if you
really believe six hundred dollars is
gonna change your life you're an
idiot really
i mean i've been broke and i never even
then thought six hundred dollars would
change my life
back when six hundred dollars was a lot
of money it's a million dollars huh
you know i mean really it's i've been
broke
i mean with 600 help yeah if you hand it
to me i'll take it
right but i'm not gonna get it obviously
because i don't meet the income
qualifications which i shouldn't get it
none of you
should get it but um but you're going to
because the government is here to save
the day it's like a cartoon
so so howling the misfit toys up there
man how much of it is
is just that dave which is it's a it's a
signal
look how much we're helping yeah that's
all it is it's look at us we're here to
help
and my point is is that they're lying to
you they're not really helping you
right if 600 or 1400 completely changes
your life you're
you're screwed yeah you already had
major structural crap
in your life you're struggling with
mental illness you're struggling with a
career problem
you're struggling with uh a work ethic
problem you've got character issues
you've got oh now he's shaming
the poor uh you know which is the other
thing i mean that's absolutely asinine
i'm not doing any of that
there's only one way that your life is i
mean you could have tremendous health
problems right that would be it it
wouldn't be shaming anybody it's just
a mathematical arithmetic arithmetic
recognition that six hundred dollars is
not much money
right and
we've talked about this a lot on this
show that
how many households in america can't
handle a 400
emergency nobody can but again that the
point is
is that you're looking to the government
to fix your life and as long as you wait
on washington dc to fix your life you're
going to suck
your life is gonna suck yeah and that's
not poor shaming
no that's shaming stupidity if you
believe
six hundred dollars is gonna change your
life you're stupid
you should be ashamed and so what is
give us like what are people going to do
right now and say
i don't i don't want to be in a
situation where 600 is going to turn
things around for me yeah well you have
to start doing the stuff that we teach
and you say okay what am i going to do
i've got the stuff you deal with on your
show which is what i was thinking of
when i said that sometimes i hear
things on your show people have mental
health issues and and things going on in
their lives and it prohibits them from
making a good life
until they get that fixed gotcha okay
that's what you're saying and keeps them
from making an income yeah right
and sometimes they're on ken coleman's
show and they don't have a career line
going up and they're making no money
they're starving to death and they
really have got to rework their thoughts
on their career and their job
and they need to make more money right
they need to work more they need to work
in a better place
a different place whatever i've been
there yeah you know i got to change
things when they're not working
right oh and by the way you ought to do
the dave ramsey baby steps right
and save some money and get out of debt
it's not if it's when the next thing
comes and get out of debt but i mean
there's a whole package here called a
wholeness look at life
a holistic look at your life that says
if 600
fixes your life it doesn't right
it can't to me it feels like a broader
conversation about
something happened and we feel
we feel a right to not have bad things
happen
in the world the bad things are going to
happen and we it's called entitlement
we immediately look to somebody fix it
the government help yeah right yeah
to me it's bigger than a dollar amount
it's an existential crisis it's an
existential issue which is
something happened i'm not going to call
on my neighbors i'm not going to call on
my local church i'm not going to sit
down with my
fix it fix it dave does that make sense
that's the part that's hard for me to
wrap my head around
well and the the problem is
and that the fact that this is trending
number one on twitter is hilarious
but it it's sad because what it
indicates is not that dave ramsey's out
of touch or not not that i'm
not that i'm right or wrong that's not
the point the point is is that i
dared to suggest that the government is
not going to fix your life
hmm that's what i'm getting at it's
better than the dollar amount i dare to
suggest that they can't fix
your life that it's up to you to fix
your life
and you're not going to have a good life
as long as you wait on them to fix it
right i dared to suggest that
and so snowflakes are melting everywhere
they are going bananas and
uh because i what i did was i i i
basically said
your god is dead
god being your your reliance on the
government solving your problem
yeah your government is your god it is
your provider
in your little existential screwed up
head
and i just said your god the government
is dead
it cannot it cannot come through on its
promises to change your life
the democratic party cannot come through
on their promises to change your life
aoc is not going to change your life um
so and neither is the republicans right
well
i want to encourage folks who are stuck
right now well the thing is
if if you recognize that your god is
dead that means you didn't have a god
ah okay and so it's encouraging to me
or it has the potential to be
encouraging in my mind
that if you recognize who god really is
and
it is the god of the universe yeah abba
yep the great i am and it is not the
federal government
and he is your provider and he gives you
instructions that involve you dealing
with you
yes and then he adds the rain and the
sun after you do some planting
right and when we have bats that's not
poor shaming
no it's it's to me it's a it's a
community thing man you got to have
people around you dave
and when we stumble and fall you've got
to plant and there's some seasons when
like you mentioned i got a health
problem that's when there's other people
in your life that will
help when i went bankrupt it crushed me
yeah emotionally yeah spiritually yep
certainly financially yeah
i got two little babies my marriage is
hanging on by thread i was broken
and i had people say you know you did
some stupid stuff
and you know what they were right yep
and i didn't sit around get mad at them
for saying i did stupid stuff i had to
not do stupid stuff anymore that caused
me to get there
i set myself up for that yep it was my
fault
and then i had other people that came
around and put their arm around me and
said you know what
i know you're hurting and i'm here with
you yep
and that you know and those are the
people of god that do stuff like that
and so that's who's walking with you but
this idea that the government
is that you dare to mention that the
democratic party or the republican party
or congress
or the president is not going to make
your life good
if i dare say that out loud that's
blaspheming
this dead god and man they go
religiously bananas before you tweet
something
i want to challenge everybody before you
instagram put mean things on whatever
go find out the names of your
two neighbors on either side of you and
who live across the street from you
and decide you're going to lean in and
write them a note say hey how's it going
you doing okay yeah
i mean put something get to meet people
there's something positive out there
that causes somebody
to move in the right direction and what
i'm trying to do there is saying
you know don't lean on the government
because you've got a long wait
yeah you know if you're waiting on this
to fix your life your life
you're screwed yeah you're because your
philosophy of life is broken
that's right and so it's a there's a lot
of
wisdom and guidance in saying you know
don't believe in a dead god
yeah that that the god of the government
is not going to provide they cannot do
it
they cannot do it all they can give is
small representations of it so they
continue to get your vote
and when you completely sell out to them
emotionally like some of you have
you're screwed